Disney uses the same logo intro they
used for Toy Story giving me a nostalgia
boner for a much better movie if he
takes place on an island on what appears
to be a dried-up riverbed which makes me
wonder where the river is is there a
drought if so why is the surrounding
foliage still so green and why didn't
Pixar just make this an island on an
actual River the late 90s was weird era
when they were basically two different
movies for every store Dante's Peak and
volcano The Truman Show and EDD TV
without limits and Prefontaine I mean
two movies about Steve Prefontaine well
here's a bug's life not ants based on
what I saw a few seconds ago whose
plenty of grain but climber ant could
have avoided the berries altogether and
they are logistical II much harder to
carry oh and all this seems like a dick
move ants of course are an absolute
nightmare there's a reason this story
takes place outdoors if it was set in
house the viewer would definitely want
all of them dead take that baby hayden
Panettiere instead of just piling up the
offering on the ground in front of the
anthill the ants decide to precariously
stack the grains onto a leaf held up by
one large rock that's held up by nine
small rocks right next to a cliff a real
ant would not get lost in the situation
ants use pheromones to make their paths
so this guy should just be able to walk
around the sleeve to get back on track
no hesitation are those freckles liver
spots a weird infection this is nothing
compared to the twig of 93 island ants
somehow measure time by human scales and
no especial time known as 1993 also or
all the minor obstructions revered as
natural disasters even though they only
take a few seconds to overcome listed
that makes this ant so much smarter than
all the other ants carrying grain and
berries and the ant colony seems to have
some sort of educational inequality
problem that can in no way be tied to
socio economics or racial inequality
because they are ants she's got enough
on a plate already trading her daughter
yes princess Sarah the poor dear
aggressive expositional emphasis guys I
can't the princess could have easily
stood behind in without hovering at all
Anson aphids actually do have a mutual
relationship and even though that is
delightfully accurate part of this movie
the answer should treat the aphids more
like colleagues and less like pets
I tell you about trying to fly no I
didn't tell the wings growing
I'm impressed her wings were able to
lift her off the ground at all these
answer so iridescent they look like
drugstore eye shadow flicks machine is
powered by movie magic this is my new
idea for harvesting grain flicks
invention bypassed thousands of years of
harvesting innovation and jumped right
to the Industrial Revolution he's
basically a witch let's go a spherical
drop Abdul couldn't telescope you don't
believe me just look through clear
marble I'm beginning to think nothing I
do works no your inventions all work
it's just that no one gives it I need to
see to a flick doesn't say hey dot can
you grab a seed out of my machines blade
aggress oh okay everyone single-file
food to the offering studies hands
didn't just do this to begin with
instead they resorted to chaos and ran
around like a bunch of dumb humans these
ants have discovered the illuminating
power of Flores at mushrooms that
definitely exist oh contraction somehow
it's the strength to knock out a rock
weighted down by two heavier rocks since
this was so easy to knock down and it's
amazing that this poorly constructed
pedestal stayed up as long as it did it
must be a wormhole in this puddle
because the grain seems to vanish as
soon as it enters the puddle I can see
the bottom of the puddle but I can't see
any of the grain also whose genius idea
was it to put the offering stone next to
a cliff it's convenient for the
grasshoppers that the ants large
gathering room isn't any deeper into the
earth one of those circle of life kind
of thing a little Disney cross-promotion
for you bumbling idiot bad guy lackeys
saying things at inappropriate times
that are expositional ultimately helpful
to the audience cliche there's still a
few months till the rains come yeah
there's still a few months until the
rains come the ants will still be able
to collect more food for the
grasshoppers who will be dead by then
because of their two-month lifecycle as
an adult also are they saying this
happens every year they are the oldest
living grasshoppers ever leave back at
the end of the season in the last leaf
we'll just be sitting around for months
waiting for that last leaf to fall which
will be hard to verify but it sounds
great I'm starting to think this movie
is some kind of bizarre retelling of
Aesop's the ant and the grasshopper
fable but the only thing the stories
have in common is they both involve ants
and grasshoppers the paroles are a
little too comfortable sassing off to
the monarchy a violent revolution
overthrowing the royal family is
definitely on the way yeah but you're an
ant right you have those wicked claws
where you can climb up and down on
everything without a problem and do you
need a giant backpack anyway the
contents of your pack are literally all
around you the scene is brought to you
by cartoon physics cartoon physics
bending the lines of reality to
conveniently serve the movie's plot
apparently Flik has much greater mass
than I am accustomed to ants had it yeah
but wasn't it your dad that said he was
gonna die flies like stinky thinks it's
a really good stink they should have
enjoyed it you always cast me as the
broom the pole the stick that's racist
you parasite that's right oh it's a flea
please this is one of those moments that
I didn't realize I should be disgusted
by until I became an adult a ladybug
automatically makes me a girl is that it
flyboy it's also amazing that the insect
Kingdom even uses the word ladybug but
hey funny jokey Oh Francis is so
bothered with the other bugs thinking he
looks like a girl he could at least try
and look a little less like Betty Boop
this movie was way ahead of the curve on
minions it seems like this is the only
thing they actually had plant Petey
survives this
I wonder what came first the circus or
the red and white umbrella and the
animal cookie box
I guess it's technically still an easter
egg even if they just tilt up and show
it to you so beautiful movie pretends
like bugs don't really die when they're
set on fire or get electrocuted so why
are we worried about hopper again is
anyone gonna help the fireflies and PJ's
bottle they're clearly stuck this poor
bastard us to do this for hours maybe
even days maybe his whole life poopoo
platter hi
this slug missed the giant pieces of
salt on top of his food now he's going
to die to be fair you were employed by a
fleet so it's hard for me to believe you
didn't see this as a possibility this
cannot be the first time this bar has
come loose and rolled away
I'm sure this establishment is seen
plenty of fights that could cause the
same result given that it seems pretty
seedy just to make sure I understand are
they standing on a pile of dead bodies
right now
hilarious misunderstanding Lee shit
they're putting the food right next to
the fucking cliff again
did I not learn anything from the last
time also this tells me that the ants
are still propping up their offering
rock pile with that tiny rock that was
the cause of the problem earlier he's
our resident this man last year he
played the lead in picnic even though I
love this pun if I know anything kids
sure do love obscure Broadway references
insect Guernica also I realize this is
all ridiculous but even a second string
Pixar movie is pretty good - once in for
the genuinely amusing murder mural oh
look at the beautiful collars of the
blood the Bucks have read human blood in
their universe Pixar had some trouble
finding the anthropomorphism line with
this movie holy I just realized this
movie is the three amigos Jesus what are
these ants teaching their kids after
this in the mural from before I feel
like these ant kids have been watching
nothing but quitting Tarantino the wires
that rolled-up blade of grass just had a
feedback issue also with this kind of
technology they could have built a bomb
out of twigs in the urine from a horse
launch Circus circumventing they can
trapeze trap them with ease I caught in
a line that almost reveals his line with
puns cliche he is what America said
after hearing the silly love songs
circulation might be a strong word okay
bird ex machina nobody really believes I
can do this job I thought all ant Queens
had to do was reproduce which to me
sounds like a pretty sweet gig how would
you like to be the Queen's official aide
to the warrior bug that seems like a
given since he found them discount
Batman the ants are able to find twigs
that are the perfect bird torso shape
these twigs must have fallen off of a
rubber tree otherwise they would have
snapped bite it did he just say Reuben
Kincaid the manager on the purge family
between this and that's super topical
picnic shout out and I can't imagine why
this film isn't more beloved by nineties
kids they still have to gather food for
the winter right this caterpillar is
destroying their rations also
congratulations to augustus Gloop for
changing the pop culture stereotype of
Germans from murderers into clot ins
it's less horrifying by several degrees
of deadly sins
I was about to let them get away with
the ant literally windsurfing on a leaf
but that compounded with Heimlich using
leaves to float down when we all know he
would drop like a hot rock is just too
much to overlook these grasshoppers are
drunk on grain you know I'm sure this is
supposed to be evil on some level but
mosquitoes those puny little ants
outnumber us a hundred to one does hump
or not know there are hundreds of
thousands of other ant colonies he can
terrorize carrots if they rise up the
grasshoppers can literally just go
anywhere else why doesn't the black
widow and the circus gang eat any of the
ants
she's already trapping them in webs
eating them is the next logical step for
spiders how long do these ants live if
he's 70 then the Queen has to be like
400 years old right okay this is like
second base for hands taking jiminy
crickets name in vain um don't you have
to fly to get here at the very least
they had to haul this 2-car animal
cracker wagon down a steep hill and up
another one right did he drive this
thing through that huge ravine meanwhile
in the ravine Petey couldn't have
possibly navigated safely down into and
get back out of paradoxes Duke it out
with catch-22s in a no-holds-barred
battle holding bars how's hop Ernest
gang have to go before they're back at
this particular ant colony this really
seems like more trouble than it's worth
the first time hopper and his gang
showed up they all hid in the anthill
but this time they just stand around I
guess they don't want to have to fix the
roof again
didn't you hear hopper he's gonna squish
the Queen to remind him who's boss
grasshopper one reminds grasshopper to
of this conveniently within earshot up
top this creature has been on a leash
all the other times we've seen him in
this movie excluding this moment I guess
that's because we needed one additional
moment of tension with Doc well what do
you know doc can fly at the last second
just before she fell to her death who
knew that was coming
shouldn't you lead with the mom
squishing I know the burner yeah our
original plan
how can she lift anything she's
basically Marcel the shell pretended the
feet okay that work must be an aunt
thing no it's just a dumping I know
flick doesn't have much of a choice at
this point but he seems confident that
this team of second graders will be able
to fly this bird we're going to isolate
the music here Gigi
does anyone else hear them playing the
music from the opening sequence from
Aladdin during this bit is this like the
third reference to another Disney movie
we've seen how much synergy do they need
where is she I'm sorry
a magician never reveals his secrets the
circus bug seemed to expect hopper to
just accept that the queen is gone the
fake bird flies in front of the moon
revealing that it's fake yeah none of
the grasshoppers look up in enough time
to see that this bird is made of leaves
twigs and is being suspended by a threat
yeah know whose idea was this who cares
you're killing everybody anyway right
flick is all bruised up because you know
ants bruise right I hate it when someone
gives away the ending he gets eaten by
birds the anteus flicks intentions and
live happily ever after
ants are not meant to serve grasshoppers
he's right but no one even questioned
that until this movie was made don't
surf grasshoppers it's you who need us
actually no they can apparently live it
up in Mexico according to this movie the
only reason they're here right now is
that Hopper wants to teach them a lesson
so this proclamation has lost some of
its power in light of the new evidence
yeah thirty minutes ago you were warning
against this very thing
hopper forgot how to fly apparently you
as ants should have been able to detect
that long before visual proof was
necessary I'll get more grasshoppers and
be back next season because I was
apparently created in a lab and possess
a tortoise gene of some sort that keeps
me alive for years and years Oh Oh bird
ex machina coming in twice now I see say
hi to the Eagles for me with you isn't
it customary for the mother bird to chew
up the food before giving it to her baby
birds
this technique here promises to shove
this big grasshopper down the middle
chicks beak leaving the other two hungry
and this one in need of surgery imagine
some Russians playing with Hitler's
index finger like a toy shortly after
the end of World War two basically
what's going on here they didn't do this
before and this may explain how they
navigated that ravine but it doesn't
explain why they were driving on the
ground in the middle of it if Tim could
do this all along and decides he can't
that noise well this seems like yet
another colossal waste of food
you didn't know you didn't know you
didn't hear me when I said very
important this morning what good are you
do you have a brain do you want to keep
this job shut up
listen learn
you need to fuck off and go back to west
world
sure it is true what many of you have
heard the machines have gathered an army
and as I speak that Army is drawing
nearer to our home what do they get
their Apes but they're not so big we got
five minutes backs it's no big deal
just engine failure good thing I only
need three never give up never surrender
wherever there is injustice you will
find us wherever there is suffering
we'll be there